[Music]  deuce Bigalow male gigolo I still say  this is a classic angry movie and the  only reason I got Meg is Adam hadn't  decided to make a decision  leave me alone I'll make something just  fight him only guy who okayed it he  produced it yeah I feel it now we were  all together with Todd garner from the  dish from Disney right and he kept  telling me about this movie he wanted to  do it on Lansing's i picturing walt  disney spinning in his grave [ __ ] and  that gives me the girls very really  doing George Bigelow originally called  deuce Baggio male prostitute  Joe Rossiter Roger we spend 12 million  dollars in a movie called douchebag I  got your [ __ ] mind your baby oh yeah  but I thought so too